For your wallets, thank you. You guys are awesome
I'm sorry back at Grandma Josie
Hey Liam. Hey dad
But uh punch he shocked me with yesterday. That was just a warning shot. So this is where you work. I own it
I actually did something with my life after you walked out. I
Know you you're that country star my mama. Listen, she's not really my cup of tea. No offense
I'm taking Billy. How old are you Billy?
seven I
Didn't find out that I was pregnant until a couple weeks after I was supposed to be our wedding day. What's going on?
How many land turns out I have a daughter
I have no right to ask for much here at all. But I want to get to know Billy
This is moving way too fast. I like teddy bears, right?
Yeah, when I was four no I am what's got into you
I said I wanted to meet him but I never said I'd be easy on him. She's got a process
You're gonna ruin your dinner with that, you know, sometimes you just gotta let go take a walk on the wild side
It's got your smile. You know, it's got your laugh to reverie
Nothing's gonna happen between us
I
never said it was
Leo you missed the whole concert that's
20,000 fans wondering where Liam pages you think you ready to be dead. She spent a couple weeks by your house
I'm not sure how long I'm gonna be here for
What happened to you
Um, why'd you leave my mama I was young I got lost what you found your way back now, right
Where's your car right here, you know the steps we'll survive in an accident in a convertible there and blow
staggeringly low
I'll pick you up in my dad's car give you those stats on convertibles, huh? Yeah
You